FOR FRIDAY AUGUST TWENTY FOURTH
IS HEREBY COLD ORDER.
PC ADVICE AND AUDIO AND VIDEO
RECORDING OF TODAY'S PERCEIVED
AS BEING MADE.
AS ALSO BEING TELEVISED TIME FOR
TRAPEZE CALL THE ROLL COOLEY.
HERE CUNNINGHAM CARILLO HERE
SURVIVED THEIR GALLAGHER GRAYSON
HAVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE YEAH MAGUS HERE
KNOWS AREA SALAS PRESENT
WALDRON.
EVERY PART.
WE HAVE A QUORUM --
PLEASE NOT NOW.
WE HAVE A QUORUM.
A WE HAVE A CONSENT AGENDA
TODAY.
AND OF THE FIRST OF THE CONSENT
AGENDA IS.
S. B. FOR NINETEEN JOINT
COAUTHORED BY SENATOR PORTANTINO
AND SENATOR LEYVA.
AND THIS RELATES --
TO WHISTLEBLOWER PROTECTIONS
PERTAINS THE LEGISLATURE --
WE ARE ACCEPTING SOME MINOR
AMENDMENT SO THE CONSENT MOTION
THEY WON'T BE --
WHAT DISTRICT THIS MEASURE AS
AMENDED?
BUT I'VE INVITED US CENTER
PORTANTINO CENTER LEYVA COMING
ADDRESS JUST BRIEFLY.
BECAUSE THE SIGNIFICANCE OF THIS
TOPIC.
AS WE TAKE UP IT I THINK YOU
VERY MUCH.
FOR JOINING US TODAY.
I CAN ABSOLUTELY GOOD FOR ME
HOUSE EVERY ONCE MORE. FOR FOUR
YEARS BEING IN THE SUMMARY ROLES
COMMITTEE SO I'M HAPPY TO BE
HERE.
AS JOINT OFF THEIR OF S. BEFORE
NINETEEN AND THE VICE CHAIR
EVELYN [inaudible]
OBVIOUSLY STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
MIXTURE APPRECIATE CENTER
PORTANTINO FOR HAVING THE IDEA
AND OFFERING THE BILL.
THAT'S BEFORE NINETEEN MAKES A
NECESSARY STATEMENT IT MAKES IT
EXPLICITLY CLEAR THAT THE
LEGISLATURE CANNOT RETALIATE
AGAINST A LEGISLATIVE EMPLOYEES
OR LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE FOR
FINALLY A COMPLAINT.
TESTIFYNG FOR ASSISTING IN A
PROCEEDING RELATED TO A
VIOLATION OF THE CALIFORNIA FAIR
EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING ACT.
IT ITS CRITICAL THE EMPLOYEES
AND GREATER CAPITAL COMMUNITY
FEEL SAFE.
TODAY THIS HAS CERTAINLY BEEN
ONE OF THE BIGGEST ISSUE SAID
I'VE HEARD FROM SOUTH.
THE LACK OF FEELING SAFE AND
PROTECT HER IN COMING FORWARD.
TO OUR STATE IF OUR STAFF YOU
FEEL SAFE COMING FORWARD THEN
HOW.
AND WILL INDIVIDUALS IN OTHER
PROFESSIONS EVER FEEL SAFE.
THE LEGISLATURE MUST LEAD BY
EXAMPLE.
ULTIMATELY WE MUST MAKE SURE
THAT OUR STAFF AND GREATER
CAPITAL NINO THAT WE HEAR THEM
WE BELIEVE THEM AND WANT TO
RECREATE REGAIN THEIR TRUST.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY THANK
YOU.
SENATE PORTANTINO MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS WHICH IS SAD.
WORD ISSUE IT'S FATHER DAUGHTER
SEND SOMEONE WHO HAS.
I BROUGHT.
FOR WHICH FLOOR PROTECTION.
IN THE LEGISLATURE AND PRACTICE
EARLY AS TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN OR
TWO THOUSAND TEN THIS IS.
PASSION AND IMPORTANT ISSUE
PLEASED TO HAVE DRAIN OUT THERE
WITH.
SENATOR LEYVA AND ANOTHER CHAIR
THE COMMITTEE TAKE THIS ISSUE
VERY SERIOUSLY.
HAS WORKED DILIGENTLY TO GET.
TO PLACE WHERE PROTECT.
BOTH ADVOCATES AND LEGISLATIVE
STAFFERS AND WITH THAT
RESPECTFULLY ASK HER NINE VOTES.
PRE SHARE ALL THE WORK IS
DILIGENCE SYSTEM IS VERY
IMPORTANT.
WELL I THINK YOU VERY MUCH I
THINK PEOPLE --
WITH.
MOTION ANTICS TO PASS A CEMENT
WHAT STRUCK DIED IN ONE AND
COULD. TO PASS THE STRICT
BASKETS AND COUNTER --
MOVE BY MISTER.
SALAS SECONDED BY THEIR SURVIVAL
SO.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL COOLEY AYE
COOLEY AYE CUNNINGHAM CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE CERVANTES AYE
CERVANTES AYE GALLAGHER CREATION
BY GRAYSON AYE KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE AYE MAYES.
MAYES AYE NAZARIAN TYPE NAZARIAN
AYE SALAS SALAS AYE WALDRON.
VOCES PASSED ANOTHER THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME TODAY
WORK ON NTIA